Muslim Americans are our friends and our
neighbors our co-workers our sports
heroes and yes they are of men and women
in uniform who are willing to die in
defense of our country
we cannot turn against one another by
letting this fight be defined as a war
between America and Islam it sounds to
me that the president is more interested
in protecting the reputation of Islam
that he is in protecting the American
people from our very clear Wyatt the
cynicism tonight to spend a significant
amount of time talking about
discrimination against Muslims where is
their widespread evidence that we have a
problem in America with discrimination
against Muslim we need to be talking
about border security we need to be
talking about terrorists and how they
get to our country and in fact I think
we need to stop I think we need to have
a moratorium on new immigration from the
middle east until we get a grip on who's
here and whether or not they've come to
attack us
you